I told you yesterday that President
Barack Obama signed a bill on Friday
authorizing 170 million dollars for the
problem of the lead tainted drinking
water in Flint Michigan the water there
has been tainted by lead for roughly
three years as much as the hundred and
seventy million dollars will help even
that isn't going to be enough to replace
all of the lead tainted piping that
needs to be replaced well Republicans
I'm sure getting behind helping to
figure out what went on there right
right wrong Republicans in the House
have quietly closed a nearly year-long
investigation into this disaster they
never received really important
information from the Republican governor
of Michigan Rick Snyder and instead they
said oh you know what we'll do we'll
blame the EPA on Friday just hours after
the top Democrat on the House Oversight
Committee
Maryland's congressman Elijah Cummings
called for a subpoena of the Republican
governor of Michigan who we know at this
point appointed the emergency manager
who's decided to switch Flint's water
supply we heard from congressman jason
Chaffetz that the congressional
investigation is over
and instead we are going to blame
Michigan's Department of Environmental
Quality as well as the state EPA now
Democrats are saying wait a second wait
a second jason Chaffetz is the guy who
was all over investigating what we now
know to be the Planned Parenthood hoax
he was all over investigating Hillary
Clinton and the Benghazi conspiracy
theory he was all over investigating the
IRS non scandal that we determined was
not actually unfairly scrutinizing
right-wing nonprofits this is the
investigator in chief and now Chaffetz
Pat shuts this whole thing down and says
let's just blame the EPA how convenient
by the way when you have an
administration coming in that
fundamentally thinks the EPA is
superfluous and should have less power
it's almost like you're suggesting that
there's a political angle to
investigations it's interesting too when
you wash these testimonies because you
have the Democrats blaming Rick Snyder
and the Michigan government yeah and
then you have the Republicans blaming
the EPA but who's really at responsible
here it's
it's very obvious and we also know that
15 past and current members of Rick
Snyder's administration refused requests
to even talk to the committee before
jason chaffetz shut it down the epa
makes a really attractive scape
scapegoat for the right if you're trying
to cast doubt into the value of the epa
into the legitimacy of the epa
this is now the paradigm and once again
and I know that we're saying this a lot
lately LED tainted water that last three
years should not be a partisan issue
we're talking about water whether you
think climate change is impacted by
human activities on earth or not the
people who made decisions that prevented
clean drinking water from being
available need to be held accountable
and this is one of those cases where
this is a state issue is being brought
up air pollution water problems these
are not issues controlled by imaginary
state lines this reminds me of the
smoking area on airplanes we've talked
about this before I remember being
younger we're on flights to Argentina on
international flights you could still
smoke on planes and I remember thinking
it's a it's a completely enclosed place
what what does it mean that we have a
smoking section and in the same way air
pollution and climate change and ground
water a tainting and and all of this
stuff it does not respect state lines
and the idea that this is merely a state
issue is just so ridiculous yeah these
are things that are considered Commons
and it goes even further than that it's
not just the lines between countries I
mean this is a concern to the entire
world absolutely no not just lines
between states but rather a concern to
the entire world when we talk about
radiation coming across the Pacific
Ocean to the west coast of the United
States it is so abundantly clear that if
we continue with this hey we've got
lines on the map separating us from
other countries there's lines on the map
separating Michigan from other states
we're going downhill quickly and we're
already seeing that make sure you
discuss this or any other stories on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash read it
indeed EIT back after this Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed
dot-com slash TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I liked the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing